[Musique]
pour beaucoup de gens est un art c'est
avant tout un personnage un unique et
pour d'autres encore un extraordinaire
scientifique et finalement tout le monde
oublie le peintre dans cette affaire et
nous ce que nous avons essayé de faire
c'est de montrer que en dépit de la
parente diversité de ses préoccupations
la peinture est ce qui faisait l'unité
de sa vie c'est un peu comme si on
recrée un atelier léonard de vinci et
aldo le tableau les dessins
préparatoires et l'imagerie scientifique
aussi qui permet de comprendre tout ce
qui s'est passé pendant cinq dix quinze
ans c'est grâce à ça qu'on a tous ses
tableaux
j'ai mis mon cément l'oeuvre qui est
derrière inquiets l'incrédulité de cinq
ans de véro que le m 2 les honneurs et
nous avons commencé l'exposition par
cette sculpture extraordinaire parce que
la peinture de léonard vient
initialement à notre sens de cet univers
de la sculpture il était un peintre qui
avait fini par penser que l'on pouvait
être nécessaire de rester jusqu'à 15 ans
sur une peinture sans jamais la finir
c'était un peintre pour qui la peinture
était une science une science supérieure
à toutes les autres sciences
[Musique]
les hommes de leonardo vinci elles ont
500 ans c'est énorme
ce sont des oeuvres qui avec le temps se
sont toujours un peu abîmée par exemple
léonard peints sur du bois
la planche de bois elle s'est déformée
quand vous posez la joconde swing table
elle est complètement déformé les
complexes et puis elle fissures qui part
du haut et qui arrive juste au niveau du
front le danger c'est que si on a une
rupture du climat ou les vibrations trop
forte
ça casse en deux et le visage de la
joconde sera cassée en beurre
d'une certaine façon le monde politique
s'est emparé du sujet léonard pour faire
valoir ses différences
alors c'est pour ça qu'on a eu pendant
plusieurs années quelques difficultés on
a eu ce dernier événement ou une
association a attaqué la décision l'état
italien de prêter l'homme de vitruve
devant donc un tribunal
on avait réservé un mur entier pour le
ce maillot merveilleux des cinq un des
chefs-d'oeuvre de la nar de vinci et
c'est vrai que jusqu'au dernier moment
deux jours avant l'inauguration s'est
dit mais est-ce qu'il va vraiment venir
[Musique]
vincent est ce que tu sais pourquoi
léonard est tellement admirée de nos
jours finalement j'arrive jamais
répondre à cette question vraiment
chacun y voit ce qu'il souhaite ce qu'il
aime ce dont ils rêvent
[Musique]